this is where we got to write we're like
okay the normal distribution it's cool
it's useful but up until the end of
yesterday we've never really thought
about what's the probability density
function of the normal distribution we'd
looked at numbers we were like what's
your mean what's your standard deviation
we just looked at the concrete details
we call them empirical data right but
then at the very end we introduced these
guys and we kind of promptly felt ill
because it just looks terrible
right now the particular point at which
I left you on a cliffhanger was when you
start with a probability density
function you're gonna go to work out
probabilities or variants or anything
you like you're gonna go there by
integrating right so the cumulative
distribution function is what you get
when you integrate this guy you remember
that right now the only problem is and
I'm not gonna write it up again but the
only problem is when you get to try and
think about this guy you run into some
trouble right and you're like was it
really necessary to print that out in
the answer is yes it absolutely was
necessary because we have to justify why
from here we're going to go in one of
three different directions and you need
to have these directions now because
they're going to give us they're going
to chart the path for us to the end of
the term which is like a whole 48 hours
away but anyway okay we've got one of
three options to choose to deal with
this particular problem right I do not
want to integrate this thing I will do
anything I can to avoid this even though
it's like technically possible so we've
got three alternatives and very
conveniently I promised I didn't plan
this it's just the way it is we've got
three ways to deal with this and they
all start with the letter T so this
integral that you get and it's mess out
of it the first thing is you can just
hand it off to technology you can just
say okay I've got software i've got i've
got des monts geogebra Wolfram Alpha or
whatever you want right even though we
don't want to do this by hand computers
can all right that's something we can
deal with using you know that kind of
software if we have it right but often
you don't have access to that kind of
like you don't get to bring your laptop
in with you during a test something like
that right so that leads to these are
the two methods that start with T
today's one that we're going to handle
is the trapezoidal rule because if you
think back to integral calculus the
whole point of talking about trapezoidal
right at the end of that topic was to
say sometimes you get an integral and
you're like I don't know what to do with
it but I can still approximate a value
by thinking about areas under curves you
can find areas using whatever shape you
like right and then tomorrow we're gonna
go look at one-third last way which is a
table of values we call it a statistical
table which kind of basically is is this
right you take the numbers that
technology has arrived at and then
you're like print them out here are the
numbers and then use them interpret them
as appropriate
okay so as promised this is the one
we're going to focus on today and what
we're going to do is I'm gonna try and
hit two birds with one stone okay number
one I'm going to show you how this works
with this particular probability density
function but secondly I want to try and
get at this weird chestnut which we've
sort of been assuming and I really hate
when we assume like something is true
and don't give any reasons why you know
when you start from the mean in a
standard sorry in a normal distribution
and then you go out one standard
deviation here's the mean and then we go
out in the highest part the bell curve
right we say that there's a certain
percentage of people that we expect to
be within one standard deviation does
anyone remember what it is it's 68 very
good it's 68 percent right that's within
one standard deviation you go again go
one more step you go further out from
the middle of the bell curve does n
remember the next number it's 95 okay we
get to the seven when we go a third
standard deviation away it's quite Ward
that's that's ninety-nine point seven
now we handed you these numbers and
we're all like they just are okay like
we came down from Mount Sinai and we're
like here they are written on tablets of
stone but we had no idea why they were
the case we're going to unpack where
these numbers come from by means of this
okay and we're only going to do one of
them because once we do one of them I
think the first one is the easiest one
um the rest of them sort of follow in
the same way you can use exactly the
same techniques but we might as well
just try the easiest one which is the
first one okay so little subheading
which is trapezoidal rule
with the normal distribution and
obviously to use the trapezoidal rule we
need to remember what is the trapezoidal
rule again like it was a whole topic and
a half ago if you have your reference
sheets there you can use it okay well
let's see if we let's see if we can do
this okay firstly remember it's a way of
approximating areas under curves right
so if you have an integral right if you
have some kind of integral I would
normally write f of X DX but I do notice
that I don't like the f of X version of
this normal distribution because it's
just a teeny bit nicer okay so instead
of writing f of X DX I'm gonna write f
of Z DZ okay it's just a different
printing rule it's fine it still works
the same way we're going to approximate
so they can write Wiggly equal signs and
then we think about how you do the area
of a trapezium hmm so what I'm going to
do is I'm just gonna write over here you
don't have to write this down but maybe
it will help for you this is just the
area of a single trapezium that's just
one trapezium when we say height we mean
like the perpendicular height what R and
B they're they're the two parallel sides
right so we would say this is for one
trapezium how do we bring that in over
here now I'm actually gonna take this
same H thing that's comes out the front
right I've got to work out the heights
of all of my trapeziums then I'm going
to use and then comes in well a bit of a
mess right these parallel sides if you
have a think about you know if I gave
you some random function like this the
parallel sides all run vertically do you
remember that right and see you like or
here's a trapezium there's a trapezium
you get the idea okay
so because they're all very cool I get
them from function values does this ring
a bell at all so we would normally write
something like f of a that's your first
function value you're also gonna have f
of B that's your last function value and
then all your ones in the middle you see
all these ones like say uh here's
another color say this guy right here
here's a function value right here it
gets used twice one by the trapezium on
the left and one by the trapezium on the
right do you remember that because this
is ringing a bell it's on the reference
sheet
so what I do is for every other function
value I double it okay
there's the first one there's the last
one and all the rest I have to do them
twice so how would I write this I would
normally say something like I'll just
take your first function value I mean
Zed's take your your second one and just
keep going like however many middle
values you've got just just put them all
in there and then you're um then you're
done
okay now this guy more or less is on the
reference shape so here are all your
function values here your first one you
got your last one your middle ones and I
just have one more question how do we
work out this H business that's right at
the front how do we work out the height
of each of the trapeziums you wanna have
a guy's right okay so I am definitely
going to use the difference between
let's call that a and that B so this is
the distance here the difference between
B na I find that distance by subtracting
do you agree that B minus a when you
have a look here like just I just made
this up right
how many trapeziums do I have I've got
like one two three four five in this
case right so if I have five trapeziums
B minus a is not the height of each
trapezium it'd be B minus a divided by
well in this case five by five because I
have five trapeziums right if I had if I
had three trapeziums I'd divide by three
if I had a million trapezium to get the
idea right so we generalized this by
saying n where n is the number of
trapezium so I'm gonna write in here
this is B minus a over N okay